did broken air conditioning cost LeBron
and the heat a title in the 2014 NBA
Finals in game one the Heat and the
Spurs were in a dog fight heading into
the fourth quarter an AC malfunction at
the at T Center caused temperatures to
swell past 90 degrees making it a
physically testing environment for both
teams but LeBron suffered the most from
it with 3 minutes and 59 seconds
remaining in the fourth quarter in the
Heat trailing 94-92 the king exited the
game in agony due to muscle cramps the
Spurs seized the opportunity with LeBron
out finishing game one on a 16-3 run to
protect home court coach Popovich joked
about it after the win thank you hope
the team would pay their bill next time
but the heat weren't thrilled about the
situation particularly LeBron who
claimed he lost a couple days worth of
fluids in that game as frustrated as
LeBron was the heat went on to steal
game 2 and shift the series back to
Miami nevertheless it was clear that the
Spurs were the better team in the end
after they crushed the heat in the next
three games and hoisted their fifth
title in franchise history but all of us
including LeBron may always remember
that game as the one that got away